Let's take a look at how the
exact that really looks like
I have a recursive function where what
I'm looking for first is if I have
reached the maximum depth
that I would like to,
if I say that I would drive to them there
by volunteers and this is going to be
fine. Did I did that? I reach
this number of policies? Yes.
Okay. Done. Just top at the time of
that and that all will be is the space
that what I'm looking for these,
the nearest intersection you
remember from the previous lecture,
that means I with actually before yours,
which I sold eat.
So what I'm just did,
he said,
I am intersecting a lot of objects and
I'm only interested in the very first
intersection
and if I didn't take anything then I will
be to a black color because there's no
energy.
Oh boy. Uh, in this room,
wow.
If I have the intersection of the object,
I will be interested in the ignition
and the material of this object and we
shouldn't means that if this is a light
source that is going to happen and the
material can be RB,
the RDF,
it feels philosophy or some complicated
[inaudible]
material. This, I'm going to
store on that. What's up next?
Well, I went back to
construct a new, right.
You guess I would face the next grade
so I can I is that she has a low rate.
This was start wherever
I think this object,
so if I keep them feeble I will create
a new radar starts on the people and I
will set the outgoing direction
according to Samhsa, the up.
Let's see that what they have here.
If it says it's random and you need to
back already he have a sphere ball where
the object was.
It sounds like it'd be a few speed for me,
so I generate the random
you'll need factor is,
and this is going to be the outgoing,
correct.
Now let's add together the
elements of the random equation.
I have the cosign that you thought
was just the light attenuation.
I have to be already at term.
And even the BRDF term,
it seems that here they have also
included is the the art, which is the lie,
that animation.
This is the veto of the material.
Okay,
how much light is absorbed
and how much it's reflected.
And then what I would like to do is I
want to call the very same function that
you see the
well number one.
So this is a recursive function.
I would start the same process again
with the new grade, those starting point
and he'd be out if I had
phrased a sufficient number
of race time exit this week,
Persia,
I collect the result of this in this
variable that's called reflected.
And in the end,
this is the elegant and patient.
Rather than get Queneisha [inaudible],
he l me plus the integrated option,
which is the BRDF times,
uh,
this reflected which is older,
the personal terms,
what do you mean stuff out this way?
We have these here and there's
going to be many subsequent boxes.
And I ended up all this energy
input reflected in family life.
So this is a pseudo false,
this is not,
this is not something that you should
fight the file or anything like that,
but this is what we bill the code.
Do you need done next lecture?
This is just a schematic overview
review on what is happening exactly.
It's like who do you shoot away,
you bounce it to the scene and then we
hopefully get the light sources and even
if we hit the lights
or should we continue?
Do you think the light
source is important?
Because this is where
we short term passport.
Let me show you what's what's going on.
If we don't need light sources.
So is Lee is the initial
term on the left side here.
So we add this to the help
resolve every coach stuff.
And a fundamental question is that if we
have a long life path that doesn't keep
the light source,
we are using completely random stuff.
Maybe sauce mark important.
Stop me.
Well yeah he never, they're
never happy submission. Okay.
What does this mean?
That the regions that we,
we give we get from the
program is going to be zero.
So the Corolla or you have
this is that won't be,
you won't get food from all
the lighthouse that keep alive.
So if you don't get the lights off,
you don't know where the light is
coming from. So you will be a black. So,
and this is obviously a really bad and
because you're computing churning out
samples out samples and samples perhaps
on your Gpu, but then it doesn't fit
the fact the QT or effect of all simple
life path crazy is that if you have a
small light source,
if Americans off yours,
you're finally just going to be slower.
Why
smaller light sources more Merriam's
stolen those Benito run the race,
the load source smaller than you
want to do this. Exactly. Exactly.
Be less for a small life and up to the
extreme where we have at 0.5 source and
if we have a point back source then we'll
see that we will be in trouble because
what I would expect from my officers to
return something like what we imagined
the point light source.
Yeah,
but this is not what we will end up with
so I wouldn't expect him to
return the correct results.
Many people have reported many
forums on the Internet that hey,
I implemented it but this is what I got.
Wow,
this,
this doesn't work at all on
all these pronounced law.
So now it's a little tunnel inflection,
wanting cower individually
for a black image.
I mean I could generate this
with five months of c plus plus.
Why? Why do we even bother?
We will get nothing.
Why is that point light
source like image quiet.
Okay.
Yes,
exactly.
Exactly.
Sort of point
represents a location in mathematics.
He doesn't not have area,
so technically it is the same.
Getting appointed by the source is
impossible because you said it the same as
what you study statistics and probably
can feel that if you have one member in a
continuous scale. What is the
problem of hitting this number?
Zero because that's what the
point it has local service center.
If you smoke you cannot get it.
Okay,
so they sent the reason
off your [inaudible] fine
not.
We could also sound our findings,
Internet meme style if you will.
So if you would like to
compute or facing that source,
we're not a technique that is
called next amount destination.
Then usually we'll
expect a wonderful image,
but this is what you're looking at.
Okay.
The first question is obviously
how will you work? Calendars
we give you is that every
time we add something,
some object and just be it the fuse
for anything but not light sources,
we can view the direct effect of
the light source on this point.
Okay,
so this is a schematic to show what is
going on. So I started from the viewer.
I hit this theater and I don't just
start placing the luminary outwards,
but I will connect this point to the
light source and I compute the director
limitation.
This is the schematic for PAF facing
without the next event estimation and this
is with next event estimations sweat.
Every station I connect
to the light source.
In this case this is actually a polluted
in this case this is the biddable and
then the third bounce you will get some
contributions from the light source.
The question is how do we do this exactly?
Well this is the topic is what's
the talking about the silence.
The formula that you see
in the assignments you is
exactly the very same thing.
Okay.
What wasn't there? Well, what
were you going interested in is
there was the term with the four or
five because if you have a light source
that's a sphere than what you would then
be or interested in how much we answers
admitted in one direction so then you
will need to divide by the area of the
surface which is a division by four pipe
and there's going to be the attenuation
through which is all squared.
Same as in the gravitational law or
even law electric fields. It needs that.
The first and a way I am from the
lights or the last month is going to,
this is the really good technique because
of multiple reasons and one of the
reasons is that you will get contributions
every mouse to the building to life.
Before I proceed,
I would like to tell you that here is,
we are talking about this and you shutter
and we are adding this parts of this
admission in every boss.
So if I hit p one I had the something if
I need to be too. I had this something.
If I eat wheat and I also add something,
but when I hit the light source,
I don't have the initial term anymore
because I will be at me get hooked yet.
So this one attribute that you would
add when you get the light source,
by chance, this is distributed
into an individual policy.
Why is this great?
We kind of have a point light sources
because the direct effect you can actually
measure, but you cannot hit the
light sources. So that's great tool.
We'll have less parents because it's not
like I either eat the light source for,
I don't.
I statistically always would be the
light source unless there are computers.
So I'm handling many samples with small
variances and that's what's happened.
And monitoring because you either
win or you don't get anything.
So I can lower the variance,
which means that my images
will convert faster.
And the other thing is that because
there are contributions of every bounce,
I can separate director the
direction of the nation.
So a lot of people do this
in that industry because
the movie industry is nowadays
using outbreaks in there.
Can I see that as a ball and
Karposi something statement.
But for instance,
Disney Disney's mouth and using it in
the nation and what he did death most
mostly politics. Why?
Because it looks insane.
The good and it is very simple and took
that more than 20 years for them to
replace their old system,
which they really liked it school base.
Okay.
And that, that'll be our musical freedom
office anytime they have a long time.
But the benefits of global illumination,
our mouth to the professor
and what they aren't doing is that
they get the physical invasions result.
But this is that always what the artists
are looking for is if you have worked
together with artists.
Okay,
the name of safe. Okay. You have
to do to the beautiful image.
But I would like the showers
together bit brighter.
Okay.
Do you view as the engineer say that
this is not possible and you didn't,
what will happen in physical
reality and that's it.
But the artists are interested
in physical reality.
They are interested in their own thoughts
and they're all not just the condition.
And he would make a change the shadows.
So you could in fact be really make one
off the light sources there and that the
shadows would get,
but that the audience has pain but
don't change anything else in the see,
just take the shadows and then you
could pull out their knowledge of the
relevant information that look the
radiance coming out from this point,
it cancel the surroundings so you cannot
just need something brighter and the
nearby things, we'll also get fried there.
You cannot circumvent why do you can't,
what you can do with the Max amount,
because condition is that you tick,
you generate an image from the first box,
so you will get one image which is
which you deposit the radiance that you
measured in Piedmont. That's something.
And then you pay for that matter we need,
which will only contain
the second pharmacists,
[inaudible] and poppers.
So you would have multiple images and
you could then I'm going to just add up.
All of these images would symbolization
that you want to get a physical reality.
Great,
but if the artist says that I was
stronger and directed in the nation,
then you would have this bathroom is the
image that holds up the second and the
higher order advances and you could do
some photos off or you can do whatever
you want with that without
touching anything else.
So you have a nice separation for
direct and indirect elimination,
moving industry, sorry, movie industry.
They are all the time and in the later
you will see some algorithms that became
differently on the indirect elimination
and differently on direct examination.
You can only do that if
you separate these firms.
So let's see, part facing now
with Max demand destination,
I have the very first bounce
and before I continue my way,
I will send the classical super,
super classical show rate.
So the light source,
a randomly chosen point of the light
and I wouldn't have this direct
contribution of delights source to
this point. And then I come to you,
let's go back to the time. Sorry. We
used managers for the very same thing.
This is why I'm writing all of these
terms because if you at the forums,
if you read papers, you will see these
terms and they all mean the same.
So exquisite light,
something Max demand customization I say,
so I continue my rate and I also hit the
light source would just chat away and
then I continue on and on and imagine
that this third one is an odd way that
actually it's the light
source and you find the mood.
I don't add the healthy part because
I did in the previous policy.
It's very important.
Now you have seen the
results or one five source,
nothing versus something.
That's what you have to.
But even if you have a reasonably
big light source, the light light,
light sauce,
I old you that you'd have various
suppression effect as well.
So this is sign off on something for,
because I think it's two,
maybe three cycles per pixel.
So this means that I grew up walking
soul and my do we race so we won't be far
also?
No,
this,
you can do it two different ways because
if you start to use vendors that we
will see how this exactly happens.
San renderers are entering the piles.
So what they do is that they start with
something source and if you say I want
Zappos per, then we'll start off,
take one more floor or whatever.
Not all the threats you
have on the other sheet.
If we take 47 four weeks old and it was
shooting more and more Saturday school
and after you've got to
long house on samples,
it was stop and show you.
It would be good input version
and what we fall progressive
rather Amy's the opposite.
You pick one thing so you should to
refuel it but only one and then you go to
the next and then you go to the them
and then see you in an image that
has a lot of noise and progressing
progressively. You look at
lesson, this is what you see here.
It's progressing rather
no,
no one asked him at destination.
So we only got contributions if
we hit this light source in here.
So we look at the blood
sample now closely.
This is with last demand destination.
So there's a huge difference.
Such a symbol that he,
yes,
magazines with orders of. Great. Awesome.
Okay.
You can also play with this program, by
the way. He says he did sheet, right?
So when you read this at home,
just [inaudible] wait a minute.
It's amazing, dude. Fuck.